- Good afternoon folks.
Hope everybody's doing fine.
So what we'll do is,
it is, as all of you know,
it's an exciting time to be in tech.
There is a significant
expectations from AI
to give productivity
in our day-to-day work.
On the right you see
that by next three years,
15 to 20% of our day-to-day work
is to be done by agentic AI.
But the reality is on the left.
Everyday in an enterprise,
an average employee on an
overall enterprise level,
there are a thousand applications
that employees use to get their work done.
How do we bridge the gap between
the complexity and the
promise of productivity?
That's where IBM has
IBM watsonx Orchestrate.
It's an open-end governed
interoperable platform for agents
targeted for business users.
Agents sprawl is real.
Every ERP vendor,
every hyperscaler as you see
around our building agents.
For business users,
abstracting this complexity
is very important.
Orchestrate plays a role of that,
or that simplification of this agentic
escheat for an end user.
On the left you see that
Orchestrate supports agents
coming from anywhere.
You can build natively.
You can bring agents built
in an open source platform.
You can connect agents running on a third,
third party platform.
And we have pre-built agents
for specific domains built by IBM.
And you also have traditional business
automation tools like
robotic cross automation,
or business automation
workflows that you always,
that companies have already
invested in, and they want,
they can connect into
orchestration engine through MCP.
So that's on your left.
And you have an end-to-end
management layer at the bottom,
which essentially allows you to govern
and monitor these agents
that are built anywhere else,
but running in orchestrate.
And we have the unified experience layer
for end users to abstract
away this complexity.
All they have to care about is
what is the goal that they wanna achieve.
And the orchestration actually delegates
the task to every agent,
whether they're built natively
or they're built across anywhere.
Or it could be traditional automations,
especially for the things that you want,
fixed set of actions to
be taken by the agents.
Over next 17 to 18 minutes,
what we'll go through is, what is it...
We'll take a use case,
a complex use case in enterprise setup
and how agents that are built natively
and elsewhere can orchestrate
and fulfill that goal of end users.
I have Jyotsna taking over.
- Thank you, Sampath.
Hi everyone. Hey.
So let's look over the shoulder of Sam,
our persona, who is an
order fulfillment manager.
This is the day in her life.
Her primary job is to make
sure she receives the orders
and ensures they're delivered on time.
So she goes to Sterling OMS,
which is her order management system
to look at the status of the orders.
And if there are any suppliers,
information that she requires,
or has to create purchase requisitions,
she goes to a procurement
system like Coupa or SAP.
And to see if there are any
tickets raised by her customers,
she goes to Salesforce,
ServiceNow, those sort of systems.
And then to just to make sure,
and she works in heavy industry.
To make sure all of
her shipping is on time
and is not disrupted due to weather,
she of course has to check
the weather information,
and goes to Google, or a news informa,
a news outlet to make sure that the global
supply chain policies have not changed.
And then she does a lot of analysis
by pulling information over to
Excel and does manipulations.
And finally, if she's stuck
anywhere or need help,
there's really not much
place that she goes to.
So now we wanna show how
her life can be transformed
when IBM watsonx Orchestrate
and AgentCore comes together
to really transform her experience
through a conversational AI.
So all she has to do as somebody
who's new to the organization
and who might not be familiar
with all of the different
backend applications
and the nuances to it,
she can interact with Orchestrate
through the natural language query
so that it understands her intents,
it routes it to the various agents
that it has at its disposal,
triggers the right tools,
and helps her accomplish her task.
So upcoming, I have a
recorded demo that's embedded.
I'll talk through it,
but you can watch her
experience on the screen.
So this is Orchestrate Chat experience.
It comes with the builder
tool, observability tool,
all under one unified platform.
So she starts her day with
showing the orders for Steelix,
her primary account.
Orchestrate understands the intent
and pulls together a series of tools,
changes them to accomplish the outcome,
and surfaces that outcome back
to her in a readable format.
So the first thing first,
all of her interactions are registered
through the AgentCore Memory Services.
Now this, as you heard Swami this morning,
really helps in
personalizing her experience
as these memory gets saved
over a period of time.
And you could also enable analytics on it.
Like, "How are the suppliers?"
"Where are the delays?"
"How are my orders doing?"
So on and so forth, over a period of time.
Now the agent was able to
invoke the sterling OMS tools
where the order information is stored,
and render it back to her
in a consumable fashion,
so she understands her orders at a glance.
And it also provides a narrative on what
are the orders that are
actually in blocked status,
and what are the impact due to it.
Now she can also double click on certain
orders to understand more.
Now this order specifically,
she got a query about,
so it has to go on time.
So now she understands it's back-ordered,
and also it's a platinum customer.
So she can't offer any
sort of (indistinct) here.
So the agent provides
a root case analysis on
why the order is blocked,
and also provides her with strategies
on how to fulfill these orders.
So there are a number of strategies
that are laid out here from
reallocation inventory,
from a lower tier to platinum,
or finding an alternate sourcing.
So in this case she
picks alternate sourcing.
So she creates this complex query
to search the catalog for a certain item,
find the suppliers who
can provide that item,
and also find the cheapest
supplier amongst them,
and go ahead and to create
the purchase requisition.
Orchestrate has the Coupa
agents ask its collaborators.
As I mentioned, it can collaborate
across multiple agents.
So now it understands
this is not something
for the Sterling OMS agent,
but for the procurement agent,
and routes it to that in
order to fulfill her ask.
It breaks it down into multiple tasks
and accomplishes, accomplishes
them in a sequence.
It also identifies that she's
missing a few information.
"Okay. You asked me to
create a requisition,
but for how many items?"
So she, it has that multi-turn
conversation with Sam
to guide her through the process
to get the missing information,
and then go ahead and create
the purchase requisition.
It also provides her the rational
of why it selected supplier two.
Because you asked me for
the cheapest supplier,
and then all of the in information
in a consolidated manner.
Again, shipping information is missing.
So it comes back and asks
for that information next.
Now once all of the purchase
requisition is completed,
it then now asks her to the next step
in the process is to go ahead and submit.
The other key pieces.
This, as you can imagine within Coupa,
and there is another system, Sterling OMS,
which does not have an
integration between them,
but because they both are
collaborating agents on Orchestrate,
Orchestrate provides that
soft bridge integration
so that organizations don't
have to spend the time
and effort integrating all
of these systems yourself.
Now she was able to take
the purchase requisition from the Coupa,
and then sync it back to Sterling OMS,
or to the ServiceNow, you know,
whatever systems of
record that's required,
with the required information.
So this is the Coupa in the backend
where the purchase requisition
is actually created
by the trigger from Orchestrate.
Now, because all of these information
has been recorded using
AgentCore Memory Services,
she can retrieve it back,
both in this chat interface,
as well as in a different thread,
and continue the
conversation from then on.
So it really helps to
store that long-term memory
so she can pick that conversation back up
on different day or on a different thread.
Now she wants to make sure
she did the right things.
So she's asking the agent
to summarize what she did,
and send it as an email to her manager
so her manager can be
rest assured that Sam,
a new employee followed the procedures,
and the policies that are
required within the organization.
Now let's take a quick look at
behind the scenes on what happens.
So this is the catalog of Orchestrate,
the primary landing page for builders.
And we have around 200
pre-built domain agents
across different domains and
to different applications.
I mentioned about the IBM systems,
but we also have for
ServiceNow, Oracle, Workday.
Depending on what your
starting point use cases,
you can come here to pick the agent,
and then explore the agent that you need.
And with a click as used as template,
you can take it back to
your builder experience.
Within the builder experience,
you have full control
to customize your agent.
Because we understand every
organization is unique.
Pre-built agents could take you
to 30, 40% of your use case,
but then the controls are in your hand.
You can pick and choose
the model of your choice.
In this case, we have integrated
with the bedrock models.
So we are using the
Claude Sonnet 4.5 from the, from Bedrock.
And I can add additional tools,
I can add additional agents,
and I also have the
control to add instructions
through the simple no-code
experience to make sure
that the agent behaves in the way
that I want it to behave.
Now, we saw Sam in
interacting with the agent
through the Orchestrate chat experience.
But this can also be embedded
within the channel of her choice.
If Sam is always on Teams or Slack,
then this agent can also
be integrated there,
so it provides that easy access for her.
And then any tools, we can consume tools,
we can add tools here from MCP server,
or we can also create our
own tools through Python
and add it to the Agent
Builder experience.
And as I mentioned
about the collaboration.
So orchestration is key for any
business use case that we have out there.
We know it's not just one task,
it's a series of tasks that
needs to be accomplished.
And the more and more
you're able to orchestrate,
the more time and effort that
you're actually able to save.
So we are able to add agents
that are natively built on Orchestrate,
or are built elsewhere,
and bring them back
through the A to A protocol
or the chat completions API.
And this preview on the site
gives the builder an
easy experience to test
and make sure that the agent behaves
the way it intends to behave.
And then we have a
unified connection manager
which allows the the builder to give,
give authentication security connections
to all of the backend tools
that Sam's supposed to have,
like the Sterling OMS connections,
or the Coupa connections which are
seamless behind the
scenes so agent is able
to hop across these
different collaborating
agents to accomplish the tasks.
Now moving on, what did we see?
We brought together IBM's
orchestration engine
along with the AgentCore services in order
to create a real life use case to life.
So as a fulfillment team,
the IBM watsonx Orchestrator
has two types of personas.
The business users who are able to
with little technical expertise
build their own agents
through the no-code agent builder.
And of course the developers,
we have an agent development kit
through which they're able
to build Pro-code agents,
and then make them available
on the UI experience as well.
And there's any channel
of engagement as we saw.
And then a series of
agents from the catalog,
or from the external agents
that are built elsewhere,
or natively built on Orchestrate
can all be put together through
our orchestration engine.
And then Orchestrate runs on AWS.
We are available on AWS marketplace
and use all of the services
that are available.
And also now we are able
to leverage the AgentCore services.
We showed memory, we
showed the Bedrock models.
We are able to do the same
thing with observability,
and really provide that
one unified experience
to understand how are your agents running,
where are the errors, how many failures,
what are the, what are the
tools that were in worked,
whether any tool
hallucinations that happened,
how many tokens were exchanged.
All of them can also be monitored
on Orchestrate's in-built
analytics dashboard.
So the benefits as I me mentioned,
the way these agents
can be brought together
is really up to the
creativity of the end user.
So it provides that
proactive intelligence.
You are able to now,
the next time I log in,
if it nodes Steelix is my primary account,
it can surface up and say,
"Hey, here are the orders from Steelix."
And then it can provide real
time insights and show it here.
But imagine having a,
we can have a weather tool which says,
"Okay, your shipment node
is coming from city one,
where at this time of the year,
there are a lot of weather disruptions."
So you might wanna choose
an alternate sourcing route
through a different city.
So it's able to now provide you that level
of recommendations without me
having to go do those look-ups.
And then I spoke about the
multi-agent collaboration.
We saw what it could do
by bringing in two disparate systems
like Sterling and Coupa and
SAP onto a unified platform.
And then the observability,
no we were not able to go deeper into it,
but do in the platform,
we have the analytics
dashboard which provides
a unified observability,
and we are soon adding observability
even for third party agents
because that's been the biggest challenge.
Now I have observability
on my native agents,
how do I know what's
happening on the third party?
But you're able to bring
all of them on a unified experience.
And then the memory is able to
provide you with preferences
and analytics based on
the past experience.
Now, so I really wanted to close
with this slide where we are,
what works available today
are the AI assistance.
We are all using co-pilots in different,
you know, capacities now
where we are working high,
high now is this high impact workflows
which really provides the lift
on productivity, and becomes,
AI agents become part of your
everyday business use case,
be it sales, procurement, talent, finance,
support, HR and so on and so forth.
And these are the starting point use cases
that we have as part of our catalog.
And this really becomes
that stepping stone
for that next level,
which is really the frontier
for fully autonomous AI agents to play in.
Because there are a lot of issues,
problems to solve in
from trust, reliability,
and you must have heard
a lot about it this week.
But that's truly unlocks
and enables really small teams
to be able to do high impactful work.
Thank you so much for listening to us.
So we are at booth there,
the IBM booth there.
You can walk right up there,
and then do sign up for a
free trial of Orchestrate.
Thank you.
(audience applauding lightly)